Good afternoon, this is your captain speaking with just a little flight information.
Coming up on the left, we're going to be catching a glimpse of the Grand Canyon,...
...on the right you can be able to see the Hoover Dam in just a few minutes.
We're flying at an altitude of 37,000 feet and our airspeed is 400 miles an hour.
Couple little facts here,...
...I'm packing a Colt King Cobra, that's a .357 caliber firearm,...
..with a black rubber grip and a six inch barrel.
Also, the copilot is carrying a Kimber Custom Defense pistol...
..with all the bells and whistles you'd expect from a custom gun of that kind,...
...with an alloy frame and bevel treatment on the entire gun.
And our chief flight attendant, Roger, has a Ruger Bearcat,...
...a .22 with a hand-fluted cylinder.
All three are capable of piercing body armor at a distance of up to 27 feet...
...and can put a hole in human bone and flesh the size of the Grand Canyon,...
...which, by the way, is coming up on the left hand side of the plane,...
...so just sit back and relax and enjoy the rest of the flight.